exactly one year ago
a disease caused by a new coronavirus
was named
since then kovac 19 has claimed over 110
000 lives in the uk alone and created
new images
that will define our age but what have
we learned over those 12 months and are
we now repeating
old mistakes this is coveted crisis
learning the lessons
[Music]
good evening i'm sophie ridge welcome to
a series of special programmes examining
the uk's response
to the coronavirus pandemic behind it a
comprehensive and detailed analysis
of every significant moment of an
extraordinary year
over the next three nights we'll be
joined by the leaders who shaped that
response
and by some of the millions of people
whose lives the virus has changed
forever joining us tonight professor
neil ferguson from imperial college
london a key member of the government's
advisory group sage
plus sir david nicholson who as chief
executive of nhs england
led the health service through the swine
flu outbreak joining them as we analyze
the details the data
and the successes and failures of the
response to the pandemic
a professor devi schrider a senior
advisor on covert 19 to the scottish
government
and the former head of the civil service
lord bob curse lake
now we'll hear from them in a moment but
first a reminder of how 12 months of
personal
tragedy pioneering science and political
uncertainty
have changed our world starting with the
lessons around lockdowns and the effect
on the british people young and old
held her around not letting anyone like
careful tied by themselves
i don't think anybody really understands
how difficult it is
on a daily basis it will like fodder on
the infantry line
if too many people become seriously
unwell
at one time the nhs will be unable to
handle it
from this evening i must give the
british people a very simple
instruction you must stay at home
i do think that we can turn the tide
within the next 12 weeks guided by the
science
we'll act at the right time you're just
stripping the shelves
today we need to go further the united
kingdom is now in lockdown
please go home we are part of a
community and we have to help each other
not going to school anymore how do you
feel about it
it's a moment when people across the uk
come together just need to buckle down
for a couple weeks months and just get
out of the way
the prime minister is in intensive care
tonight another 786 patients have died
in the uk an increase
of 938 an increase of 881. more than 10
000 deaths couldn't even be there to
hold my mom's hand
we will take a phased approach free
opening schools
you can do this then you can't do this
very confusing they ruined my results
this is not what i deserved
feeling quite happy about coming back to
school
although i'm quite stressed quite
accustomed to seeing scotland do one
thing wales to another
it's a complete mess it's just ruining
that first year at uni we're in a
position where we don't know what's
wrong corner
england will go into a second national
lockdown
it's just more than 50 000 people have
now died
cannot continue with christmas as
planned
sick and tired of this when is this
going to stop people are not at the end
with the
locked animals we now have a new variant
of the virus the united kingdom will be
under a lockdown from midnight
i think people are tired nobody knows
what they're doing to the
uk has surpassed 100
000 deaths we do know that things will
be better
in this country by easter
such a sobering year let's hear from our
panel then i just want to start with a
personal reflection what's the one
moment
event or memory that's really stood out
to you this year
professor ferguson to you first
it's a difficult question to answer i
would just reflect that a year ago today
i'm the team i lead at imperial college
we're just about to release tomorrow a
year ago
the report which first estimated the
death
rate of this virus to be one percent of
those who might be infected
and i suppose it was that day and
the following two weeks really
the momentous nature of what we were
doing and what we were living through
became really clear to myself and my
colleagues
just in terms of what the likely impact
was going to be on society
almost regardless of what policy was
adopted either
through lockdown which would hopefully
limit the death tale but have huge other
consequences
or god forbid if if lockdown wasn't
adopted yeah we'll
go back to that pivotal moment later on
in the programme as well
um so david nicholson what memory stands
out to you
i think uh so at the moment i'm also the
chair of worcester acute hospitals
nhs trust and i think the thing that
stands out for me is we
as you might expect we're professionally
getting our plans together we're dusting
down all the plans looking at all the
kind of
emergency plans in place and putting all
the governance arrangements in place to
make sure we could manage
through it and then one evening most of
us
saw some of this the pictures coming out
of
northern italy and that i think really
brought it home to
everybody about what was really
happening italy have got a you know
decent healthcare system in fact they
you know ahead of population had more
intensive care beds than we had
and they were clearly being overwhelmed
and that in a sense made it much more
real and much more human i think you
know
that we were getting ourselves ready but
we didn't really know what for
and then we saw the human consequences
of getting it wrong and that really did
i think galvanize
people i mean one of the things about
healthcare systems generally is that
people are very proactive they're only
interested
in their own but actually medicine is
global
and it was amazing how many people we
had in the hospital
doctors in particular who had contacts
relatives or had worked in italy
or new people in italy and suddenly we
were inundated with
face times with clinicians on the front
line
pictures of patients advice about how to
do it
and it really galvanized everybody i
think to really
move forward and do some absolutely
marvelous things yeah
certainly those images from italy
something i'll never forget as well
let's um pick up with the rest of our
panel now shall we uh professor sherida
what's the one memory
that stands out to you from the last 12
months
i think it goes back to last january
when there was a memo sent out by the
world health organization that there was
a novel pathogen that china had reported
and no one really knew how bad it was
until january 23rd
when wuhan went into lockdown we saw 11
million people get put into lockdown for
500 cases
and soon after hospitals build within a
week we knew this was not the flu this
was something fast moving it was human
to human
and they were chinese government was
scared and was actually then moved to
lockdown 66 million people we had never
seen anything like that
and that was the moment we saw countries
start running you know taiwan south
korea
um you know east asian countries because
they knew this was something that was
very dangerous and they had to get ahead
of it
and finally law cursed lake is there a
personal memory or significant moment
that you will always remember
yes well my mind initially went to uh
the uh press conference by dominic
cummings
on the 25th of may in the rose garden
somewhere i know
but actually i want to give a more
personal reflection
recently at an event one of the speakers
said
we haven't had time to grieve to mark
the terrible losses and the terrible
impact on people's
lives that covert has wrought on us
and at the end of the event he shared
with us that his
sister had died and i think we'll all
have those
deep personal stories that we need at
some point
to recognize and reflect and grieve on
thank you very much to all of you for
sharing those
experiences with us now to help us learn
the lessons sky news has compiled the
most detailed timeline of the thousands
of events decisions
statistics and stories published by any
uk
media outlet now this helps us to
understand the opportunities that were
taken
and those that were missed so we can
start with lockdowns and compare the
government's first decision to lock down
the country
with what happened in january this year
now the first
known death from covert 19 is reported
on the 11th of january 2020s after a man
died
in wuhan now the world health
organization looks into
what happened at the market at the
center of the outbreak this is what it
concludes that there is
no clear evidence that the virus passes
easily from person to person
it goes on to say the who does not
recommend
any specific health measures for
travellers
11 days later on the 22nd of january
professor
neil ferguson is at the first stage
meeting of the year i'm just going to
read you some of the
minutes there is evidence of
person-to-person transmission
it's unknown whether transmission is
sustainable
and it takes until the second of
february for the uk government to issue
its first piece of public health advice
wash your hands
but it's not until the 10th sage meeting
on the 25th of february
more than a month after that first
meeting that sage discusses measures
like
isolating working from home for the
first time
now let's go to the third of march when
the government publishes its coronavirus
action plan
where it's admitted that up to a fifth
of the workforce may be off sick during
the peak
in a news conference later that day
boris johnson says he
shook hands with everybody on a hospital
visit
and it's worth pointing out a paper from
the stage meeting on exactly the same
day
says this there was agreement that the
government should advise
against greetings such as shaking hands
and hugging now a week later on the 10th
of march the cheltenham festival goes
ahead
150 000 racing fans
gather over four days and on the same
day
sage concedes that there is a need to
reassess the advice on the risks around
public gatherings
and then just a day later on the 11th of
march the world health organization
declares
this is a global pandemic on the 16th of
march boris johnson tells the public to
only make essential
journeys now by this time scientists at
imperial college london are projecting
that if the uk does nothing
510 000 people could die from covet
by august now during march italy spain
and france all impose a series
of lockdown restrictions and then on
march the 19th
sky news reports from the italian city
of bergamo
revealing to the world the scale of the
catastrophe
engulfing the italian healthcare system
they're fighting a war here and they're
losing
the sheer numbers of people succumbing
to the corona virus
is overwhelming every hospital in
northern italy
the staff are working flat out trying to
keep these people from deteriorating
further
they're trying to stop them from dying
the doctors
say they've seen nothing like it before
and are warning other countries
especially the united kingdom
that they will see it as well
and this is the moment four days later
on the 23rd of march
england wales scotland and northern
ireland enter a national
lockdown now let's compare that sequence
of
events with what happened at the end of
the year we can fast forward all the way
to december the third and the first
stage meeting after the country's
second lockdown ends now the minutes
show
that they warn the government's plan for
christmas bubbles could prove
deadly they point to a slight shift
towards a higher proportion of cases in
older
and more vulnerable age groups which
could lead to an
increase in hospitalizations ten days
later
on the 14th of december the health
secretary matt hancock announces that a
new variant has been found in the south
of england
with over a thousand cases identified
restrictions are tightened in some
regions but shops are still open
foreign travelers untested schools fully
staffed
now by the 17th of december the
netherlands and germany are in lockdown
france italy and spain
have national curfews and we can look at
the stage meeting for that day this is
what they say
it's concerning that case rates are
continuing to rise in areas that have
been in tier three
since the relaxation of national
measures additional interventions may
need to be considered
or there needs to be an increase in
adherence to existing measures now two
days later boris johnson announces
that london the southeast and the east
of england are going to go into a new
tier 4 measures less strict in march but
the announcement triggers a huge surge
in travel
with long queues at london stations
now by new year's eve 44 million people
that's 78
of england's population are in tier 4
and on the 4th of january the prime
minister announces a new
national lockdown now by now 40
more people are in hospital with
coronavirus than at the peak
of the first wave last april
well let's go straight to professor
ferguson at shall we now
you warned on the 27th of february that
half a million people
could die we didn't lock down for
another 25 days
was that too late
clearly with the benefit of hindsight it
it was i mean i think one of the key
lessons learned
in this pandemic is that if you lock
down earlier
um you don't suffer the same deaths and
and paradoxically there isn't really a
trade-off with the economy because you
probably can lift lock down measures
earlier too you just keep infection
levels
low and the report of ours you mentioned
in the london school of hygiene and
tropical medicine did the same
analysis predicted way back in march
that we would have to go into periodic
lockdown to keep this
epidemic under control and that's
exactly what we've seen
i think circumstances were a little
different coming up to the third
lockdown
sense that a lot of information came in
really quite quickly around the new
parents and how much more transmissible
it was so it did
in some ways come out of the blue but
it's undoubtedly true you just need to
look at the data
well over half of the people who died in
this pandemic in this country have died
in the last eight weeks
you say that the new variant came out
the blue but at the same time
you know it was we knew how infectious
it was on around the 18th of december
didn't lock down for some time after
that and i know you said that
you could have present prevented around
half the number of deaths in the first
wave just by looking down
a week earlier did we not learn the
lessons there either
i think we could have responded faster
but actually i think the tightening of
measures particularly around tier four
and then these cutting back on christmas
um celebrations helped we would have
been in a much worse position
had that not happened um i think
as i said before i mean we would have
been
in a better position for the winter had
we locked down earlier in the autumn i
think the most disappointing choice
you can always go back and to march and
and say well
you know people were balancing very
difficult um considerations but by
september we knew exactly what this
virus could do
and unfortunately because in some sense
the political
consensus had fragmented um
governments across europe and it's not a
particular criticism this government
reacted too late and so it was only in
october
that we really tightened up measures and
only in november that we lock down again
and then
not really for long enough had we
learned
lessons properly from the first wave
then
we would have been a much better
situation coming into christmas much
lower infection levels let's say
and therefore fewer deaths fewer deaths
let's bring in professor
schroder at this point i mean we can see
from our graph this is the
daily deaths in the first wave uh
obviously dipping down over august but
then rising again
to a higher peak in the second wave
professor
schroeder did we learn the lessons from
the first wave
well i think the perhaps mistake that
was made was just to think about
flattening the curve
as professor neil ferguson said we could
see from the projections that health
services capacity was here
and the idea was just to stay within it
which meant periodic lockdowns of going
in and out in and out and you never
wanted to exceed it because then you'd
have people dying because they couldn't
get care
where the countries that have really
done well decided after their first
peak or first bump to keep it low not to
ever have it rise and they did that
through having a functioning
test trace isolate system actually
paying people to isolate not to infect
others having really fast testing
regimes
but also having border restrictions so
you didn't have re-importation
of new strains once you managed to clear
and get on top of the ones you had
do you think the border restrictions
that we've heard about today for example
were too slow to come in
i mean definitely and i think if we look
at the countries that have sustainably
suppressed meaning gone up gone down and
then stayed low and managed to open up
their economies and get back to normal
life
they have had border restrictions in
place and there is a trade-off there i
think we have seen which is
do you want to have a lot of daily
normal life do you want to have
schools open shops open pubs bars live
music
live sports stadiums full but you can't
go in or out of the country or off the
island
or do you actually want to have
international mobility but we live under
restrictions in our daily life and these
are the really hard decisions in a
pandemic
and we're seeing now because of the
variant and concerns over it and what it
might mean for our vaccination program
that the government is saying actually
we got to take this seriously and i
think we will see
more and more countries moving to manage
isolation norway
finland israel canada and now here in
the uk as well
well let's talk to law curse like next
shall we and scientists obviously
focusing on the best way to suppress
the virus often that is locked down but
politicians have to balance that with
lots of other things don't they
education mental health the economy do
you think the government got it about
right
well they do have to balance a lot of
things and this was an extraordinary
time you've got to recognize just
how unusual it was for any government to
face
but i think the government made a number
of errors really
firstly i think they often tried to
split the difference
rather than take decisive action in one
direction or another we've heard
some of that in others contributions to
this
discussion i also think that they listen
too much to uh the debate that was
raging in the newspapers about
um lies versus livelihoods and the fact
that the numbers were going up or going
down at any particular time
in truth this wasn't a lives versus
livelihoods debate
it was about lies or more liars being
lost
and i think they could have and should
have been more decisive i think in the
last lot line
last lockdown they have been more
decisive
in terms of their actions and that's
having an impact
but earlier on i think they were
indecisive and in fact i think in the
summer they declared victory
too early uh interesting let's uh bring
in
uh sir david at this point shall we the
uk could end up with one of the highest
death tolls
but also according to the oecd the
biggest economic hit of any major
economic country apart from argentina
and what do you think the lessons are
well first of all you have to learn them
and i i i hear all this about you know
we can't have a
we can kind of inquire into all this
because afterwards how on earth are we
going to get better the way you get
better
is to recognize what you've done and
then change as you go forward
and he didn't take a genius to work out
and you know at the time i was i'm not
engaged in the
in the national picture i'm you know the
chair of a hospital trust but we could
fairly clear and see
the case rates go up hospital like
hospital activity goes on a couple of
weeks later
and death rates go up a couple of weeks
later after that didn't take a genius to
work that
that out but it seemed to us anyway that
it wasn't being recognized by by the
center
i mean from my perspective are we
interested in bob
kersley's views on this i i just think
they got the whole thing
badly set up from the beginning now i've
been engaged in a whole load of
national uh issues although nothing like
this and it is incredibly difficult
you know when you're dealing with these
spots to make the right
the right judgments but a couple of
things that you learn from it the first
thing is that
the prime minister makes the big calls
you know no matter how you organize it
the prime minister makes the big calls
and the prime minister needs to have a
proper setup around him
to enable him to make those big calls
and what was clear to anyone looking in
is they simply hadn't got their act
together in terms of how they were going
to do that and make it happen
i say bob is a better position to do
that and the second thing was
when you're making decisions from a
national perspective
it's a real drive to make them happen
they don't just happen because you say
it
many politicians often think that you
know the
end that announcing something is the end
of the story
you know actually it's implementation
that's the big issue
and when you're doing that you have to
have the courage of your convictions
you can't half do things and that's why
you know
bob's point about uh trying to do the
middle
little range you have to have conviction
you have to
recognize it and then do it and i think
we didn't see more we still don't see
too much of that well let's let's bring
in uh lord kirsten like at that point
shall we um
what is your view is the structure of
government not really set up for this
i don't think it was set up properly at
the beginning no um and some of that
is the fault of inadequate contingency
planning
prior to the pandemic and all of us
including me
must take some responsibility for that
but i also think we had really a very
centralized approach
with a weak center that was my
observation
schools universities hospitals
shops all wanted to do the right thing
but they
found themselves struggling i think very
often
with confusing and changing
decision-making and direction
and that i think was a real challenge we
needed
to entrust local areas to make more of
the decisions
but exactly as david said we needed
uh if you like government with
conviction and clarity and
i'm afraid we didn't get that along the
way on a number of occasions
professor ferguson you were sitting in
some of those meetings with the
government
did we get that clarity of purpose was
that the leadership shame
it's a difficult question to answer i
mean i mostly interacted with
chris whittie and patrick valance who i
think have been excellent throughout
i think there were challenges i think
the major thing
we mentioned before hospitals filling up
when you're dealing with a crisis
there's always a lot of uncertainty
and there can therefore be
some sense hesitation about making
really cataclysmic decisions when
um on the basis of limit information and
i think there was an element of that and
only when
we saw hospitals start to fill up in
london when we started getting the first
reliable data through
really about the 11th 12th of march
did it clarify clarify minds i mean i
remember sitting in a sage meeting
the previous week in fact you know
looking across
the table at somebody who'll remain
nameless and saying i mean do you know
what this epidemic is going to look like
if we
if we don't act soon then and
i think that reality on the ground was
as much as anything else beyond all the
scientific advice watch
probably shifted policy initially to
announce
a swedish style voluntary lockdown on
the 16th of
march and then to the compulsory
lockdown on the 23rd of march
okay well we're talking a lot about the
health factors of lockdown
but the impact of course was really felt
on the economy particular sectors
have been devastated including
hospitality well joining us now is
someone who's felt that firsthand the
chef restauranteur and pub owner
tom carriage thank you very much for
being with us mr carriage
what a year it's been for people in your
role what how's it been like
yeah it's it's been very very difficult
i think the first is the fear factor for
people's livelihoods and jobs and
particularly your
colleagues and friends that you work
with staff and
first and foremost has been ensuring
that they feel secure in their positions
that
you know you um act as a business owner
and as a
as a leader you you're trying to ensure
that they're
um you're trying to put their minds at
rest but at the same point
you know as business owners we've also
been looking for guidance and and
some real infrastructure and
understanding of how we can get out of
this and it has been a very
very difficult year yeah i mean
the parallels and the the movement of um
the rules have constantly been changing
and
hospitality has been one of the
industries that have been at the
i suppose the cliff face of it has been
really up against it and but has
you know adhered to all government
protocols tried to be
a as as operational as possible fitting
with covered safety
but still you know we end up in this
position where we close but
you know we are like many other
industries like the arts like travel
like tourism there's a lot of businesses
and a lot of sectors that
are really struggling out facing an
uphill struggle to get out the other
side
and it must be hard when you feel
responsible for people's livelihoods
their jobs
and i noticed that seven out of ten pubs
and restaurants
uh told a uk hospitality survey in
november
that they could close in 2021 i mean
we're talking like an awful lot of
businesses here on the edge
yeah the the one thing that makes
hospitality the most amazing and
brilliant industry to be in is because
when we join it as i joined it as an 18
year old doing it because it's passion
heart
soul and love and people most people
that are in hospitality are in it
because they really enjoy doing it
they're they obviously the businesses
have to try and operate
as a profitable business but those
they're very very fine lines between
profit and loss
even if you see pubs and restaurants you
assume that just because they're super
busy on a saturday night they must be
making loads of money that's not
necessarily true you know
the ebitda and percentage margins
are really quite small so the moment
that you get those they start shrinking
away
businesses that they you know then start
operating at a loss and then
you know if businesses this year have
been
struck with a huge amount of debt being
able to service that debt company
it's very very difficult if those if
those profit margins and percentages are
really small
how then those businesses going to
service those debts um when we can
reopen is going to be very very
difficult and that
that's where it will lead to closures
and i know we talk about in this
industry
that it feels like it will be a sudden
um the moment that the furlough scheme
is removed and that government support
system is taken away that many places
will close
it won't be like that what will it be
it'll be a very slow
quite painful death for many businesses
because they'll try to reopen they'll
try and keep their staff going they'll
try and keep those movements
and try and increase that business but
you know it's not going to suddenly
bounce back and what will happen is that
the the debt load that many businesses
would have taken on over this last year
to service that debt
will be the so it will start dying off
there will be many businesses that just
can't reopen
and then there'll be many more over the
next 12 to 24 months i think that will
struggle quite a lot we've seen of
course some government support scheme
to furlough scheme the eat out to help
scheme to try and help
businesses who are really fighting for
their lives and at the beginning of
course when the pandemic first
struck things are very uncertain but do
you think things have improved in terms
of government support
i i think that government support um has
been very very good
in terms of the furlough scheme and in
terms of for staff and then
i think the word spoken have been
great in terms of for hospitality in
particular where vat being reduced
five percent um although that's great
for accommodation
and food led um we haven't been able to
be
open to make any use of that so that's
something that we would be desperate for
the transfer
particularly coming in the next budget
and to be looking at extending that that
those vat cuts so that it gives
businesses opportunity to
to move forward you know the the
business rate support scheme has been
fantastic
um that i would hugely encourage that to
be going and also the
in terms of the furlough being able to
move forward we need all of that to
regenerate and regenerate those
businesses
but what we what we really need is
government to actually
listen and when they listen we need them
to hear and take on board so
you know we found ourselves i found
myself in a relatively fortunate
position to be
a voice and being able to listen and be
a part of conversations moving forward
but what we really need is that that
voice that penetrating voice that goes
into whitehall that has a complete
understanding of the hospitality
industry
so that puts it in a much stronger
position to come to the other side
and what hospitality i mean it's an
employer of over three million people
within this country and
that's just straight into hospitality
that's not just the supply chain that's
added on top of that
which is another two million people the
farmers the the fishmongers the bakers
the
kitchen suppliers the furniture makers
all of these people that are involved in
hospitality
it's such a huge sector and what we need
is
is a kind of a positive outlook from the
government we need
we need alignment with understanding of
how we can move forward we don't want
um you know made up things you know
stories being leaked of pubs that can
open with no alcohol that's no help
that's not helpful to anybody you know
we need a clear and defined i suppose
um yeah exactly we we need information
from government requirements regarding
covert safety
we and we need a definitive plan of
action we need as much notice as
possible
for us to be able to build forward and
moving forward because hospitality isn't
just
um about pubs bars and restaurants it's
much more it's the beating heartbeat
it's a it's fabric of society it's a
network of people
that keeps moving things forward thank
you so much for coming
on the program and really kind of
outlaying the challenges facing your
industry tom carriage thank you
well let's go to professor sridhar shall
we and we heard that didn't we really i
guess
an example of why the economic argument
is something that we can't take our eye
away from um is it fair that the
government has been trying to
keep that on board as they've been doing
the government they've been trying to
find their way through the pandemic
i mean definitely and i think in public
health we are highly aware
that lockdown has consequences on health
outcomes we know
child abuse has gone up we know
inequalities are increasing with schools
being closed and unemployment is bad
for people's health and for all you know
increasing use of food banks so i think
the mistake that we've made is to try to
flatten the curve and go into repeated
cycles of lockdown instead of actually
saying
how do we exit this once and for all and
get a full domestic recovery
but that requires fully suppressing the
virus we can't lock down society forever
so the question is how do you suppress
without lockdowns and what countries are
doing it and there are countries that
are doing it who are winning
you could look across to east asia you
can look to the pacific and the way
they're doing it is through having
you know perhaps a hard lock down at the
beginning harsh
get those numbers low keep them low
through rapid testing making sure people
isolate when they're infectious
they don't feel like they have to go to
work to earn and then you also keep your
border restrictions in place not to
import new strains
and then you open up slowly and then you
will have flare-ups because the
infection is now global so when they
come up
you go hard you put out the fires and
you try to keep society running
because i think the repeated cycles of
lockdown are pretty catastrophic and i
think we are seeing the consequences
already
at the same time though is it fair to
compare the uk to other countries i mean
it's much easier to close off the
borders than new zealand that it is in
the united kingdom
you're talking about countries in asia
for example with test and traits well
they have much better surveillance of
people that they're going to be privacy
concerns about in the uk as well aren't
there
yeah so there's trade-offs and i think
that was the message that's been clear
since january and it's what do you
prioritize
and right now i would say what we've
prioritized has not worked out that well
because we're shut in our homes in a
lockdown we have hospitalities we've
heard collapsing we have kids out of
school with no easy way to get schools
open
quickly and we have a hundred thousand
deaths so obviously
the route we've taken we've taken a lot
of costs without much benefit and so i
think we should have had that discussion
over
okay is tourism going to be hit in
aviation well how do we then target our
economic support at them
but let domestic hospitality run or are
we gonna actually have more
infringements
on let's say people's movement trying to
regulate isolation
in hotels or through apps but that means
people get you know the ability to
move around their homes so i think these
are the kind of debates we had to have
because there are trade-offs in a
pandemic and trying to pretend they're
none
leads us to being forced into reactive
lockdowns
which is where we've been now been for
about a year i just want to bring in
new variants something that lots of
people are very worried about at the
moment
and professor ferguson nerve tagger said
that this mutation of the kent variant
found in
bristol today they've described as a
variant of concern
how worried should we be
i think it's concerning um the key
difference between this
variant in um in bristol
and the new variant we've been dealing
with last few months is the mutation
e484k
which is probably the difference between
uh our our new variant and and south
africa in terms of
allowing the virus to partially escape
immunity and that's the concern so it's
as transmissible as
the new variant we've been dealing with
but has this one additional mutation
which may affect and we i say may may
affect
how effective vaccines are at
protecting people and probably doesn't
have any effect on transmissibility or
severity but the key issue is
if if this virus this new variant of
concern
can even partially escape immunity
it makes control going forward that much
more problematic
i know things are very uncertain but you
know people will be worried if
this new variant could potentially
interfere with the vaccine
is this an argument for locking down
harder
for perhaps continuing the lockdown for
longer until this new variant is under
control
so certainly i mean i support the
intensive testing measures being put in
place in bristol which are trying to
detect as high higher proportion of
people who may be carrying this
this variant of concern um
and isolating them and then therefore
driving down its prevalence
as to does it require the lockdown to be
in place for longer
the one good thing at the moment is that
in all their
areas of the country and for all
variants case numbers seems to be
dropping
but relaxing does pose challenges with
new variants
um and particularly a variant which
might even partially escape immunity
if that was able to take off that would
be very problematic so
as as in throughout this pandemic there
are many factors to consider and no easy
decisions to make really
yeah no easy decisions feels like it's
been the theme of the last year
certainly and thank you all for
very interesting first discussion now i
want to focus on
education because it's been one of the
most challenging issues during the
pandemic and as our
timeline lays bare classrooms exams and
universities have all been severely
disrupted
but almost a year on students parents
and teachers are still struggling
with inconsistencies in the system so
let's look
at what happened the first time around
on wednesday the 18th of march
this is when the government announced
that schools would have to close by the
end of the week and they were reacting
to a stage meeting that day that said
the evidence now supports implementing
school closures on a national level
as soon as practicable to prevent nhs
intensive care capacity being exceeded
it's ten long weeks after that that
primary schools and nurseries start to
reopen on the first of june
just as the first lockdown starts to
come to an end but
by the 9th of june the plan for all
primary schools to be open before the
end of term is scrapped after pressure
from teaching unions
secondary schools six forms and colleges
are allowed to open
for face-to-face contact two weeks later
but many choose not to
now stage meets on the 23rd of june
and they say that there may be a need to
change measures at the end of the summer
in order to be able to keep our below
one while proceeding with a planned
reopening of schools
later that day the prime minister says a
return to school
is safe but in areas where local
lockdowns are being imposed like
this one in leicester schools are forced
to shut
again the 13th of august is a level
results day in
england according to ofqual almost 40
percent of grades in england
were marked down by one grade or more by
the standardized model
drawn up by the regulator that's 280 000
entries adjusted
students across the country are soon
protesting and within days
on the 17th the education secretary
effectively scraps
the regulator's algorithm students start
returning to university
in september even though a stage meeting
from the first warns that social
activities and living
halls pose a greater risk for
transmission
than teaching on campus on the 26th of
september
more than 30 universities are dealing
with outbreaks most prominently in
manchester
where 1 700 students are forced to stay
in their rooms
for two weeks now on the 4th of november
mps vote in favor of the second
national lockdown which will come into
force the next day schools stay open
now sage meets that day and they
reiterate school closures have an impact
on the physical and mental health
of children but on secondary schools
they are clear children aged 12 to 16
played a significantly higher role
in introducing infection into households
on the 3rd of december
students are told they can go home for
christmas if they test negative
sage meeting minutes that day say that
lateral flow testing should not be seen
as a way
on its own of enabling high risk
activities to take place
but could reduce the risk of activities
being undertaken
on the 14th of december with a more
contagious variant of the virus
confirmed
despite a warning from one council of
exponential growth that demands
immediate action
the education secretary uses legal
powers to force
two councils in london to keep schools
open
a week later the department of education
emails recommend
mass testing in schools when they reopen
in january and that day's sage meeting
hears
that r would be lower with schools
closed with the closure of secondary
schools
likely to have a greater effect than the
closure of
primary schools one week after that
gavin williamson tells mps the
overwhelming majority of primary schools
will reopen as planned the following
week
and a fourth of january despite
widespread confusion about the rules
that does happen
for a day only for boris johnson to
announce a new national lockdown for
england that evening
including the immediate closure of all
schools
at the end of january it's announced
that children won't go back to school
after the february half term as hoped
with a new target to reopen classrooms
from the 8th of march in england
that's two weeks later than planned in
scotland
and wales well let's hear
a bit about what that's all meant for
the people involved we can speak to
kieran murrell who's a
university student whose studies have
been really severely disrupted over the
last year thank you so much for being
with us i can see you're smiling now but
it's been a difficult time for students
hasn't it what's it been like
it's been absolutely awful it's been
such an incredibly lonely time
and it's felt so upsetting and
it's been so hurtful to work so hard to
get to university and be
actively encouraged to return to
university in september to
get here and have those hopes of some
sort of normality
be instantly stripped away and being
told that we wouldn't be on campus
learning with our peers
and interacting with our peers
and just tell us a bit about yourself
and what's your works where are you
studying what are you studying what's
the last few months been like
um so i'm studying at bournemouth
university i'm in my second year doing
psychology
um and the last few months have been
really hard on my mental health this is
probably the most i've
ever suffered um i felt a huge lack of
support from my own university
and i wasn't receiving feedback on
assignments in time
i should have been which meant as a
result further assignments were
suffering because
i couldn't improve myself i couldn't
work on myself so i was finding myself
really struggling and
then you know just feeling really alone
i haven't been onto campus
since march last year and that's not
looking like i'm gonna get
onto campus anytime soon again you see
we talk a lot don't we you know about
the health impact about the economic
impact do you think we've spoken enough
about the mental health impact that so
many young people are really suffering
with
absolutely not there's been a huge
increase in students mental health and
the amount of students are now going to
the
their universities in need of mental
health support that
universities are feeling incredibly
overwhelmed because you know
students are being isolated physically
and mentally you know being stuck in
student halls or in a student house
is so lonely even if you're living with
other students you're away from your
families
you know i've got some friends who
haven't been home in months they're
international students they spent
christmas alone and that's had a huge
impact on their mental health because
they're not
seeing their loved ones and they're
stuck in this country which is
completely alien to them
thank you so much for coming on the
program it's so important to hear you
know the personal experiences of people
like you we do appreciate it thank you
well let's go to lord curse lake i just
want to talk to you in your capacity of
chair of the board of governors at
sheffield hallam university just
hearing that from keira saying she just
hasn't received the support she would
want to
from her university do universities need
to take a bit of responsibility here for
not always stepping up
well my sympathies are entirely weaker i
think
she's obviously a terrible experience
and yes universities have
a big responsibility to support their
students
no university that i'm aware of wanted
to stop face to face
and it's been a real loss to us that
it's happened we're acutely aware
of the stress that it causes the
students and i think
most universities i would say i've done
a lot to put in extra support
to students to help them manage through
this very difficult time
and i think just a wider point to make
here wasn't i actually think the
government had done some good things
in relation to the economy and
employment there are very few redeeming
features as far as education is
concerned
and what's most frustrating about it is
that some of the things were both
predicted
and predictable the u-turn on exams for
example
i can't imagine what it was like for
students who were marked down and then
had to wait whilst the issue was debated
in parliament and elsewhere
so yes universities have got to deal
with this but i wanted to say a quick
word about schools
because i seriously worry there not just
about the loss of education
but the mental impact there and we are
going to need a national recovery
program
on schools as well as something to help
students recover on their education
otherwise they will be
not just temporarily damaged as this is
done but permanently damaged in their
future
careers it's an absolute responsibility
to address this in the recovery well
let's talk to professor sugar about
schools
shall we because different nations are
doing slightly different things here uh
aren't they so
in wells and scotland younger pupils
returning from the 22nd of february
in england and northern ireland schools
closed until at least the 8th of march
when should school start reacting
so i think what's absolutely clear is
that children have borne the brunt of
this pandemic and there are massive
harms to children being out of school
and schools should be
the first things to open and the last
things to close
even if we have to keep in place
restrictions in other places
and there is also an age gradient we've
learned about which is we've seen
much fewer outbreaks in nurseries and
we've seen it go up so the
older the age cohort the more outbreaks
you seem to see
so we're trying to do in scotland is
22nd of february get the youngest kids
back
early years p1 to p3 and then
you get them back to some normality
assess that and then cautiously start
expanding out to get kids back
and one of the great things that we saw
last summer was because we managed to
squash the numbers really to elimination
levels
you know we had few cases when we opened
schools 76 percent of schools
you know had no cases until you know
mid-october november
and and of the schools that had cases it
was just one
case and then test and trace came in and
was able to isolate that child without
it spreading
so there is a way to run schools
effectively but it does require
suppression so you don't keep having
cases in school
right now the restrictions are in place
the numbers are coming down let's hope
we can get schools open
okay have you been on a bit of a journey
yourself i just wonder because you know
you talked a lot at the beginning of
last year about
looking down about zero covered about
suppressing the virus and it feels more
recently
you've been talking a bit more about
schools regaining is that fair
well i think actually um you know i've
always been someone who wanted to
follow the east asian model so i think
for me because i was following this from
january and so
i was thinking we need to treat this
like a sars-like infection
and follow that model which is you know
you try to suppress it or eliminate it
you just get rid of it
and so that's been my consistent stance
but i think right now what i'm seeing is
we're a year into
this and we don't seem to have a
coherent strategy so in a way
either say we're gonna go for
elimination we shut down everything for
three weeks
we clear the virus we open everything or
we say okay we have to live with it if
we have to live with it how do we get
kids back to school because we can't be
in this position next winter
so i think that's where i've got to
which is you know we have to
get kids back because we can't sit here
in this kind of circular state of not
getting anywhere farther
professor ferguson what does a song say
about children
so it feels like it's been quite
confusing do they spread the virus
schools vectors of transmission are they
safe what's the answer
i think it's confusing because there
isn't a simple answer i
largely agree with debbie that there is
a gradient and so certainly young
children
have not been so far significantly
implicated in transmission
but teenagers particularly older
teenagers seem to transmit just as
effectively
as adults and have many more contacts
and i think the difficulty we face now
with the new variant which i should
emphasize doesn't specifically target
teenagers or children but it is overall
50 to 70 more transmissible than the
variance we've had before
and that means the reopening schools
poses some risks
i agree with the scottish approach of a
staged approach of opening primary
schools first and assessing what that
does
and then only moving to opening
secondary schools
i'm also critic you know very very
conscious of
the both educational and and social harm
that keeping schools shut um entails and
therefore i completely agree again with
debbie that i mean schools are the
thing we want to open first if we're
going to open anything
so david talking about the harm to our
young people i mean you're a father
yourself i know and how
alarmed should we be about the sacrifice
our young people are making
disadvantaged children in particular i
guess
absolutely and in any environment where
mortality
is the issue children always suffer
you know in anything that we we we try
and do and we need to mitigate for that
and this kind of reinforces this
this idea about conviction about what
you can do if you
believe that opening schools
and it has to be the right thing is a
big priority
for us then we should do stuff to make
it happen
and that i mean one of the things that
struck me particularly i said at the
time
was when we opened the schools
originally during the first lockdown
for um staff who were in the nhs
that was a test bed for us to learn how
to do it and to arrange it when we did
it we do
now we have the schools open for
for uh for frontline staff we should be
testing and learning
how best to do that so that when we do
do it we're
particularly well organized i mean if
you if you look at mental health
services in the nhs at the moment they
are potentially overwhelmed
by child mental health quite serious
mental health problems amongst
children um around all of this and this
is a this is a
big issue i think that uh bob ferguson
talked about in terms of the restoration
about how we're going to make this much
better for children
um going going forward but i think you
know
getting the schools open you know if it
means
and i've you know uh clever people than
we can work this one out but if it means
vaccinating teachers we should vaccinate
you know
if that is our priority then we should
do whatever it takes
to make it happen and don't sort of you
know
fiddle around the edges and hope
something's going to happen
because all of our experience here is
that
you know the old adage i remember when i
we did uh other things and the chief
medical retirement
liam johnson was an extraordinary
cautious uh
individual in lots of ways you know this
idea of hoping
uh for the best but planning for the
worst on almost every occasion now it's
been the worst
good advice there it feels like there's
been quite a lot of agreement on the
importance of opening schools and i just
want to pick up on something that uh
professor schroeder said a few moments
ago about what things could look like in
a year
professor ferguson what do you think
things will look like in the year
everything is going to be completely
back to normal are we going to have a
low level of restriction
what do you think
so i think the vaccine we're rolling out
now will have a very major effect on
deaths
with the caveat i think we'll need to
implement another vaccination program in
the autumn to deal with new variants and
perhaps
even sooner than that but with the
levels of uptake which are
very encouraging we're seeing in older
people
over 90 percent in the over 75s that
will
even though the vaccines are not perfect
that will still have a very major impact
it's not going to allow us to go
completely back to normal
um certainly not until the autumn and i
suspect
there will be new things we can't
predict precisely like the waning of
immunity like new variants coming up
which means there will be some residual
need to maintain
some social distancing mask wearing
probably for much of this year but as
vaccine manufacturing capacity gets
ever greater and as we update the
vaccines and get ever more effective
vaccines
i'm hoping that by next time next this
time next year
it will look a lot more normal maybe
there'll still be mask wearing for mass
gatherings and things like that but we
certainly i very much doubt we'll be
anything like
where we are now interesting uh thank
you so potentially some
low-level social distancing mask wearing
even into
next year professor do you agree with
that the fact that actually
some sort of restrictions could be here
for a lot longer than we perhaps
anticipated
yeah well i think the thing we want to
avoid is having the situation this
winter
largely the economy being closed and
schools being shut and having the nhs
almost overwhelmed and i think people
should be optimistic
because we do have a number of vaccines
last january we weren't even sure we'd
have one vaccine and now we have at
least five
which are safe and effective and
especially the mrna vaccines can be
changed for the new variants if they can
do that quickly enough and get out
so i think right now where are things
going best case we see that vaccine roll
out
in six to eight months in the summer we
have most of the population covered by
the autumn even vaccinating children and
other being trialed in children
in the united states and then you kind
of reach the status where if they stop
transmission
we can actually you know continue on
quite normally like how we've dealt with
other infectious diseases
the variants are the real unknown and
right now the south african variant the
brazilian one these are warning signs to
us we might be able to manage these
but as long as the virus is circulating
somewhere in the world it could always
come back in a
slightly different form and a more
challenging form and we need to plan for
that
to avoid it because we don't want to be
in another lockdown interesting it does
feel like covert 19 could be with us for
quite a long time if not forever thank
you all very much for
a fascinating uh discussion of professor
ferguson
uh sir nicholson's david nicholson
professor debbie schroder and lord
bob curse lake thank you all very much
well that is it for this evening but
tomorrow we're going to be looking
at some of the measures taken to beat
the virus including of course the
vaccine rollout that we touched on
tonight and the efforts made to prevent
hospitals
from becoming overwhelmed so a lot of
the safety measures to be talked through
tomorrow i'll be joined by another
expert panel including the former health
secretary
jeremy hunt and also a former boss of
test and trace to analyze
all of the evidence tomorrow night
that's coveted crisis
learning the lessons which will be
continuing tomorrow night at 8.
thank you for watching and good night
[Music]
you